a blazing ball of fire lies deep
underground
it's earth's core
this colossal sphere of molten iron far
beneath your feet
is what made your life on earth possible
or
did it
what if earth formed without the
scorching core in its center
is a coreless planet even possible
how different would the earth be without
its core
and if it didn't exist
would you still be alive
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth had no core
underneath 2 900 kilometers of crust and
mantle lies the core of our planet
this mighty ball of molten iron has a
radius of about 3 500 kilometers and
temperatures of 10 000 degrees celsius
that's even hotter than the surface of
the sun
it was formed during the iron
catastrophe a major geological event
early in the history of our planet when
earth was heated to temperatures above
the melting point of iron
droplets of heavy metals gravitated
toward the center of the planet while
lighter elements rose to the surface and
formed its mantle and crust
the coarse scorching temperatures are
the result of energy left over from the
formation of earth and nuclear energy
from natural radioactive decay
and it's the motion of the molten metal
of the outer core that is responsible
for earth's magnetic field
you know the thing that protects us from
harmful cosmic radiation
so how nasty would things turn here if
earth formed minus its core well as
you'll see a world without a core could
be disastrous
now imagine a world without crippling
dead
what could you accomplish if you didn't
have high interest loans and credit card
debt looming over you all the time well
with upstart you can pay off your debt
with a personal loan so you move on with
your life that's why over a million
people have used upstart to consolidate
their debts into one fixed monthly
payment with a clear payoff date in just
five minutes you can check the rate you
qualify for on loans from one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars without
impacting your credit score find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
what if or click on the link in the
description below that's upstart.com
what if and don't forget to use our url
to let them know we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com what if
upstart could help you rebuild the core
of your finances
but below the earth's crust
we're on our own
in order to form planets require iron
lots of it to fall toward their center
eventually this iron becomes their core
scientists think planets with no core
could also exist
which happens when iron becomes oxidized
and trapped in a planet's silicate
mineral crystals or mantle
in these cases the iron doesn't form a
core and the planet goes on with its
day-to-day existence without a scalding
hot sphere at its center
so
what would happen if our very own earth
formed like that
well in order to be habitable a planet
requires warmth and water it needs to be
sheltered from a young violent star like
our son
a magnetic field acts as a planet's
shelter and is created when its core
cools and solidifies
distributing the liquid iron around it
and sending out electric currents as a
result
so if the earth formed without its ball
of molten iron it wouldn't have a
magnetic field
this would expose us to harmful cosmic
radiation and charged particles emitted
by our sun
we'd also be blasted by ferocious solar
winds
without its magnetic field earth could
lose its atmosphere
just look at our nearest neighbor mars
for the repercussions of that
long ago mars did have a strong magnetic
field but
it wasn't meant to last
the martian core froze around 4.2
billion years ago and
that dramatically weakened its magnetic
field
so weak that it couldn't keep its
atmosphere protected
solar winds mercilessly chipped away at
it slamming into the planet at speeds
reaching approximately 800 kilometers
per second
so you could guess what would happen to
earth if we didn't have a strong
magnetic field like we do now
instead of being a place warm enough to
store salty oceans where life could
thrive
our world would end up as a cold dry and
lifeless desert
if life on this coreless earth emerged
it would need to adapt to some extreme
changes
an intense barrage of uv rays would be a
constant threat as they could damage
your dna
most likely you would have to live
underground where you'd be less exposed
to cosmic radiation
if you stayed on the surface of a
coreless earth
you'd constantly see flashes of light
even with your eyes closed keep your
eyes
this would be the result of cosmic rays
passing through your retinas
without the magnetic field some animals
like birds and whales wouldn't be able
to navigate
all life on earth would have to adapt to
living in much harsher environments
but wait there's more
you wouldn't have all that great
technology that relies on our magnetic
field
yeah that's right satellites
telecommunications and navigation
systems
none of them would exist
i don't know about you but i'd rather be
born on mars than on a planet with no
core
and you should probably know that our
planet's core is slowly losing heat
eventually our hot ball of molten iron
will become solid
[Music]
scientists predict it would take 91
billion years for the core to go
completely solid
luckily or not
the sun would run out of fuel expand
into a red giant and swallow the earth
long before the core gets completely
cold
now the idea of living on mars seems
much more appealing to me
but you know what
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]